and I invite the president of the
European Council to take the floor
thank you and good evening to all of you
to begin with I'd like to thank
most warmly prime minister fiala for his
personal commitment to involvement of
his team
under the rotating presidency of
European Union which fell to check if
it's time they've had a very active
committed
presidency but mobilized us all to
maintain European Unity on one subject
after never ever more difficult so I pay
tribute and show my admiration before
prime minister and all your team in
Brussels and do pass on those thanks to
everyone concerned this European Council
as you know
was a European Council take place in
just one day with many subjects on the
agenda which were difficult
and we're very satisfied that on all the
subjects on the agenda we have been able
to reach decisions
where we all agreed together Unity Unity
We Stand United
and starting with Ukraine this morning a
message from President zielinski we
heard from him again what Ukraine's
immediate needs are in the current
situation I'm very committed and remain
mobilized to support Ukraine as much as
we can and this European Council
confirmed
and restated previous decisions in
particular 18 and billion of macro
financial assistance stuff for Ukraine
I agreed but shows that the EU stands by
its commitment keeps its word
also we pay tribute to decisions taken
to increase the funding available peace
facility is very important for Ukraine
and maybe also for other countries and
other regions but definitely for Ukraine
which would benefit directly from that
and we're happy to tell you also that we
managed to get an agreement on the ninth
package of sanctions
now we had to wait a a an hour or two
maybe but we want to be sure that the
procedure on the emergency side too was
fully finalized and that has been the
case as a the evening went by we've
managed to do that again we've shown our
firm attitude of condemning Ukraine's
action putting some pressure on the
Clemens War Machine whilst guaranteeing
food security and
Muse committed not due to making sure
that food security is not jeopardized my
next important item on the agenda was
our relations between the EU and the
United States we had a long strategic
debate this morning
a quality debate
to our after the last debate in the
European Castle on the subject
and there we restated in a consistent
committed way our
uh desire to be reliable and loyal Ally
of the United States in many areas we do
cooperate together Ukraine security
Democratic Values climate we're all
mobilized together there and steps
forward have been taken in that area but
we continue to encourage more steps to
be taken
and it's to be sure that uh the uh whole
debate about the inflation reduction act
in the United States is something we
talked a lot about it was an opportunity
for us
to reckon it's two important points
firstly we wish uh to talk to the us
about uh Ira to argue for uh exemptions
for European accomplishment case of
Canada and Mexico already and we are
committed to an active dialogue of
United States to defend the interests of
European business and to see how with
the United States so we can get those
taken to uh consideration in their
relationship with Europe
this follows directly on from what we're
talking about in October in the European
Council giving a mandate to the European
Commission of the Clear Vision as to
what we have we want to have something
from a b by the end of January we want
the commission to bring forth proposal
by the end of January seeking to
mobilize uh instruments uh National and
European level to support the
competitiveness of European business
serve as a strong ambition there but we
set in place a package of a measures to
give a clear signal to our business and
I mean not just a big business but also
a small medium-sized business and to
European citizens to show a mobilized uh
and we'll be there on time
and this is particularly important given
the energy crisis which is hitting us
and in the light of decisions taken by
the U.S to support American Business
it's our duty in Europe to react also
quickly we need to have a quickly
proposals to support our competitiveness
and an ambitious strategy to make sure
that we maintain our economic and social
fabric here in Europe
and the third point that I'd like to
mention
something which we talked about though
not directly on the agenda about
Schengen
today to welcome a Treasures entry into
the Schengen area it's from 1st January
2023 and we're at also the occasion to
have a political debate on the accession
in the Schengen Zone by Bulgaria and
Romania and I would like to to tell you
that I am optimistic that the decision
on Bulgaria and Romania can be taken in
the course of 2023 and and we felt a
political a political uh commitment to
to work in order to to make progress and
I sincerely hope that we'll be able to
make it happen in the course of 2023.
one word on migration it was not the
main topic on the agenda today but we
know and you know that we are facing the
increase of numbers through the Western
Balkan rules to the Mediterranean rules
and this was the occasion to open the
dean at the level of European tonsil the
burning of a debate on that important
chance on that important topic and we
have a clear agreement that in February
the 9th and 10th of February will have
an in-depth debate in the European
Council on the tradition of migration it
means that we need to prepare very well
that the debate in order to to be able
to to give to give useful orientations
and to give guidance on that very
important uh topic is more very briefly
then I refer you to the written
conclusion security defense I can see
what we decided on also we had an
exchange
views on our Southern neighborhood and
we are able to
prepare for next year
on that so where we confirmed a
recognizing and bosnia's candidate's
Status
bosniah that's a strong signal
to a Bosnian population it shows that we
also expect them to make their progress
on reforms and to strengthen and
institutions in that country
and then we had a pie talk Iran too
again you saw written in the conclusions
there so we talked about that too uh
finally on behalf of the members of
European Council we should express our
condolences to the family of the Irish
soldier who lost his life in a un
operation in Lebanon and also empathy
for victims and those who are wounded in
about situation on behalf of colleagues
I also wanted to express our sympathy
and condolences towards uh family and
victims so in a few words that was the
main points are discussed in today's
fruitful meeting and which guaranteed
yet again Unity of a European Union
where more than ever we need unity and
the strength that comes from that and
our germination Minister may I invite
you
thank you very much good evening ladies
and gentlemen Czech presidency is slowly
coming to its end and I would I would
like to thank to all our partners
leaders diplomats and especially to you
Ursula and Charles for a great
cooperation during during this
challenging and unprecedent months they
have been facing a large aggressive war
on our continent
it has not only direct impacts on our
security but also many economic
consequences especially in the field of
energy
Unity is our biggest Advantage therefore
we put all our effort into finding
acceptable compromises
to be frank
it was not always easy but together we
made it happen I am glad that we have
managed to maintain a unified approach
to our support for Ukraine I am glad
that we today approved macro financial
assistance to for Ukraine and the latest
sanctions package the Czech residences
also paid a great attention to the
consequences of the war on our citizens
mainly on the high energy prices the
energy ministers will have met seven
times in six months seven times in six
months I must say that it was not easy
but we have done all we could and I hope
we have done it successfully I believe
that the last and crucial step on this
matter will be taken on Monday's energy
Council
I would like to wish the best of luck
and a lot of energy to prime minister
wolf Christensen and to the Swedish
presidency I believe that we will be in
very good hands
now I would like to use this last
opportunity to speak as the presidency
in Czech language
ladies and gentlemen good evening
the presidency will be at his end in two
weeks time and until I want to thank all
our partners all diplomats Charles
Ursula and all others the tasks were not
easy for the Czech Republic were not
easier for the EU or for the whole of
Europe
we took over
in the middle of Russian aggression
against Ukraine it has a direct impact
on the security of member states and the
energy crisis has an impact on everybody
in Europe despite all this we remained
united we were managed to find
compromises compromises to solve
problems which any which none of us
could imagine a year ago I am glad that
we remained United
in supporting Ukraine this United
approach
is further confirmed by today's
package containing microfinancial helps
Ukraine and the ninth sanctions package
even more time work and attention were
devoted to other impacts of the war
especially
the high energy prices which concerned
all EU citizens it was not really easy
but I'm convinced we did
we did well and on Monday energy
ministers will agree on further steps to
restrict Energy prices I especially want
to thank our Czech team the Ambassador
diplomats officials
such students diplomats everyone who was
involved you did a great job and it is
also thanks to you
that I hear a lot of Praise on the
address of the Czech presidency and
finally in Czech I also want to wish the
Swedish presidency a lot of strength and
a lot of energy we are in good hands
president you have the flu thank you
good evening let me also start by
congratulating you Peter and your
fantastic team and thank you for the
excellent cooperation and the excellent
work that you have done in a very
successful Czech presidency
you took the Helm of the council at a
very difficult point in time
the war in Ukraine wasn't is sending
shock waves across the globe and
affecting everything from energy to food
security
it was essential to maintain our Unity
of purpose and unity of action
and you the Czech presidency you were
instrumental in achieving this
be it on further sanctions against
Russia or on support to Ukraine
the other very Salient success I want to
thank you for the better concerns are
most existential priority
and that is the European green deal and
in particular our fit for 55 package
under your presidency the European Union
has now agreed on an impressive number
of proposals under fit for 55.
among these the zero emission cars as of
2035 the effort sharing regulation
the carbon board adjustment mechanism
and yesterday re-power EU
and we hope to agree this weekend on the
reformant expansion of ETS and on the
social climate fund
I cannot end this list of achievements
without mentioning the conditionality
mechanism
we have triggered it for the very first
time a clear sign
that the European Union is determined to
use its prerogatives to protect the rule
of law
they're better and your team Europe owes
you a depth of gratitude for this very
impressive work that you've done
I also want to congratulate Croatia for
the introduction of the Euro next year
and its full accession to Schengen
and to Romania and Bulgaria I want to
say we stand fully behind your Schengen
accession we will continue to work
tirelessly to enable your accession to
Schengen as soon as possible next year
and finally I want also to congratulate
Bosnia hatsigovina for having obtained
candidate status this is an
encouragement to stay the course of
Reform on the European path
now we turn to 2023
I look forward to working with incoming
Swedish presidency
in particular on Ukraine and on the big
topic of competitiveness
we will continue to support Ukraine for
as long as it takes
the European Union has as you know
supported Ukraine financially this year
with
19.7 billion euros
and thanks again to the Czech presidency
our proposal on an additional 18 billion
euros for 2023 has been adopted today
the EU is at the Forefront of support to
its neighbor as it should be and will
remain so
the war has massive consequences on our
economies and this will continue next
year
we Face a potential gap of 30 BCM of gas
next winter we can fill it
but we continue to be in a very high
energy price environment
and among others action is now needed on
the joint purchase platform
it is important that we do not outbit
each other as member states that but
that we use the market power to purchase
gas
the speeding up of Permitting is crucial
for the world out of Renewables there
are many projects sitting in the
pipeline basically to be started waiting
just for the permitting and with this
permitting reform we can go ahead and of
course the market correction mechanism
I'm confident that the energy Council
next Monday will reach an agreement on
all three another success of the Czech
presidency
but against the backdrop of this very
high energy price environment we face
stiffening
competition in clean tech sectors
the United Nations the United States
decision to invest heavily in these
sectors is first of all very welcome
it's good that there's a massive
investment in the Green Field in Green
Tech
but we also on the European side need to
act to ensure that the European Union
keeps its Global Leadership in the clean
tech sectors
we need to convince cutting-edge
Industries in the European Union to
continue to invest here
and this is why I have presented a
four-point plan to leaders
that brings together all the main
strands on an effective response to the
United States inflation reduction act by
the European Union
first we are working with the Biden
Administration on the most concerning
aspects of the IRA
second we have to adjust our own state
aid rules for some years simpler faster
and even more predictable
third we need to boost European
investment to accelerate the energy
transition
in the short term this will happen
through a reinforced repower EU and in
the medium term through a new
sovereignty fund and finally on Fourth
we have to speed up the deployment of
Renewables because the whole topic is
about helping our industry to go from a
fossil fuel based energy environment
that is high price
and to transition towards a renewable
energy environment that is Affordable
homegrown and secured
So based on today's discussions
the commission will now move forward and
make concrete proposals we must and we
will act thank you very much thank you
madam president we'll take a couple of
questions here in the room Katarina you
you would like to ask a question check
news agency please
respect
um despite all the nice words about the
compromises reached over the last few
days we've also seen different countries
blocking different files for example
Hungary taking the rest of the EU
hostage and also Ukraine taking hostage
for the sake of its own interests
just today Poland was blocking the deal
in principles on the corporate taxation
that was agreed on Monday
the question that is obvious is this one
the method of the EU has always been
consensus
what do you have to say to this new veto
methodology is it this new community
method will this be the future in the
next weeks and months to come will we
see more vetoes coming is this so much
distrust among the leaders here and I
would like to ask all the presidents to
answer thank you
hmm
I think there is no need to comment the
process the result is what matters and
the result is good we managed to find a
compromise and everything was approved
macro financial assistance money for
Hungary and minimal taxation for a
company so-called pillar the second
period so there is no need to commend
the process I think the result is most
important
you show me just a few words consensus
this is exactly what we did today and
that's why the European Townsend is
playing an important word because this
is true that there are 27 member states
on all the topics uh usually uh the
starting point is not exactly the same
and it means that we need dialogue we
mean we need to negotiate sometimes we
need to be Innovative in order to try to
promote to propose compromises and
that's why we recommend the role played
by the church presidency because we were
able only only in a few days and today
only in a few hours to reach government
positions on very difficult topics and
it's true with on some of those topics
different opinions before we start the
the the the the the the the final tours
on the decisions we needed to take but
you have observed today again we are
united and we are sending a powerful
signal
I think what you have described 27
member states 450 million people
this is democracy
democracy is sometimes a bit slower that
is true but it has the respect to listen
to everybody and to four majorities
and at the very end it counts what the
outcome is
and this year with all the pressure
we've had
with the atrocious War Russia is leading
against Ukraine we have acted in
unprecedented unity and speed we have
legendary sanctions the ninth package is
approved today
massive financial support
massive military report support but this
is bilaterally
we should not underestimate that 8
million refugees from Ukraine have been
received to the European Union
the Ukraine has achieved candidate
status all topics that 11 months ago
nobody would have expected we could act
in such a determination speed and unity
and yes there is a higher price to pay
for this world that is the high energy
environment that we feel on as burden on
our company's shoulders but there are
two
a lot has happened in this year you
should not underestimate that Russia has
cut 80 percent 80 percent of its
pipeline gas and we compensated we were
able to manage there have been no
blackouts on the contrary we filled our
storages we are now safe for this winter
we have the joint platform we have
enabled the member states to skim off
windfall profits and to support
vulnerable households and vulnerable
businesses just to frame that this is
democracy it takes perhaps a bit longer
to come to a decision but when it's
serious we stick together and we deliver
thank you Suzanne please
you'll have to go to the stand sorry
I
um Suzanne Lynch from Politico
um I just have a question really for all
three really about
um the
corruption allegations that are having
both the European Parliament there
appears to have been a substantive
discussion about this between leaders
this morning and I'm just wondering
um maybe prime minister fella you could
start by saying are you worried about
the reputational damage to the EU by
these allegations and whether then to
the two presidents there are any moves
to introduce or to strengthen
transparency measures in the
institutions
of course this corruption scandal is a
question that has shaken uh Trust
in the European Parliament
in many and we have to take a reasonable
stance on this we discussed this with
Roberta metzela from the European
Parliament this morning and she
presented the measures that the European
Parliament has taken and will take in
the future
to deal with this issue but also to
prevent such situations from happening
in the future and I must say that I have
full confidence in the president of the
human Parliament and her approach
just to points yes there was a duet this
morning with President Metzler on this
topic on the one hand There Are Rules uh
corruption is criminally reprehensible
and that we have to use the mechanisms
that are disposal and it may be worth
going further to to have a prevention
measures taken and we heard from
president metzelo what the European
Parliament is going to do in this area
and then secondly a lot of confidence
was expressed in the role of the justice
system rule of law
and hopefully that will shed light on
exactly what has taken place the facts
revealed and
there was a support expressed for the EP
president for how she got to grips with
this uh very very quickly to be able to
learn lessons as soon as possible of
this institution
corruption is a crime
it has to be prosecuted and we have full
confidence and Trust in the Belgian
authorities who have the responsibility
and thus the authority to deal with that
file
but of course
events like that corruption like that
erodes the trust of the public in the
institutions and this is painful
and we have to work hard to gain again
trust and confidence
the European Parliament has voted today
on a resolution
that shows the path forward
and I'm very much looking forward to
work very closely with the president of
the European Parliament on the points
that are concerning our two institutions
for example the call for an Ethics body
of course not only concerning the two
institutions of Parliament and
commission but also Council and other
institutions of the European level and
I'm very much looking forward to work
with Roberta on that
Christian that I speak
we must work
I'd like to come back to transatlantic
relations the Americans have just
challenged the Europeans with this
colossal subsidy program do the
Europeans have the means or even the
capacity to come up with a similar
package of subsidies themselves which
would lead to a greater debt in the
member states then a second question
uh Mrs Van the lion you have proposed
some very interesting things and what
was the uh reception to your proposals
we've heard that uh the reception wasn't
very favorable uh some member states
said that we've got enough funds we
don't need to uh look elsewhere for new
funds uh well if you start like this it
doesn't all go well and then my last
question the Americans are selling gas
to us but not at Friendly prices do you
think that's the right way of dealing
with your allies
should I start okay
please wait Mercy
um so the in general the inflation
reduction act as I said initially is
something uh generally positive because
it's for the first time that the United
States invests massively in the green
transition we've waited for that for
long and therefore it's in general good
what we want is fairness
and we see that there are some worrisome
Parts in the ira first of all the buy
American logic
um that privileges American production
second tax breaks that might
discriminate European companies and
production subsidies with the same
effect
and therefore it is for us important to
work very closely with the White House
with the Biden Administration
first of all on specific exemptions that
are necessary
we are in the course of discussion about
that for example the definition of
electric vehicles
that have access to the American Market
we want the same treatment like Canada
and Mexico
secondly we have to do our own homework
and indeed the typical equivalent to tax
breaks on the European level is State
eight
and therefore we will come forward in
January
with a state aid proposal that is not
only faster and simpler but more even
more predictable
and that takes into account that we do
not only look at competition at the
single Market of the European Union but
also the global competition that we have
to take into account
the third element is important
because we know that not all member
states are able to use
state aid because of lack of fiscal
capacities or fiscal space
and therefore it is necessary to have a
Level Playing Field within the European
Union to also have
a funding element the short-term answer
is to boost repower EU we have now
repower EU repower EU is targeted
to bring investment to The crucial
points of Renewables of infrastructure
and Energy Efficiency that's exactly
what we need
in the midterm we need a structural
answer and that is the sovereignty fund
we had a very good discussion and we had
a positive reception with a lot of
positive comments on the letter that I
sent to council the leaders to frame the
discussion and that shows that there is
an immediate tasking
that we are being asked to provide A
needs assessment to provide the answer
to this competitiveness question and to
come with an overall approach as I have
described in the letter to the leaders
in Council
in fact we are facing three challenges
which have been exacerbated by Russia's
war of aggression in Ukraine on the one
hand we see that we absolutely need to
reduce our dependence on China now we've
seen the consequences of that secondly
we have to guarantee a Level Playing
Field with the USA and some of the
decisions they've taken do have an
impact and they are obliging us to
react to this to work together to
channel our efforts together and this is
what we're going to be working on in the
months to come and then thirdly
we also have to ensure that we can
guarantee the Integrity of our single
market and avoid the temptation to
fragment our single market now of course
not all member states have the same
capabilities the same margin of maneuver
to come to the support of their economy
so three challenges serious challenges
but we're all fully aware of this and we
have no choice we have to react swiftly
and determinedly which is why we beefed
up the conclusions today by asking that
all the proposals should be tabled by
the end of January next year and we are
also going to convene again on the 9th
and 10th of February in the UCO we're
going to be discussing migration back
then but we're also going to be
discussing these self-same issues in uh
February and we hope that the council
then will give a a thermostat to the
Future actions and discussions and in
fact we want to go even further we need
to look at where we can take Speedy
decisions and we need to adjust our
state aid Arrangements
now uh economic uh
foundation in the EU is that we should
give the market a free reign a free
trade
which is why often we are against the
state aid we've often criticized the
China for using state aid to uh
disrupt the Level Playing Field at a
global level so we have asked the
commission to um come up with proposals
to address the situation a second point
we need to see how we can become more
flexible in mobilizing funds existing
funds and we've got a lot of funds that
have already been mobilized in the
recovery
plans a lot of funds have not uh been
used as yet but really it takes too long
between the money being committed and
the money being spent so we need to
address this particular problem we need
greater speed and flexibility and then a
third Point
solidarity assurance the shore mechanism
will hopefully allow us to make sure
that there is also fairness across the
board in Europe and in the medium term
as the president said what we all need
to look at is a sovereign fund and this
links up to the Strategic autonomy of
the EU namely we need to ensure that we
can support the key sectors key for our
future so defense and security energy as
well
new technologies
these are the sectors that we need to
work on in a more structured approach
I think our generation is going through
greater turmoil because of this war but
it should
ensure that we actually rise to the
challenge because all of this will have
an impact not only for the months to
come but in years to come an impact on
the e-user possibility of becoming a
remaining a dominant Force
with Bloomberg I have two questions the
first one for Prime Minister sialam
President Michelle are you 100 convinced
that the ministers will reach an
agreement on the gas price Cup on Monday
in one word
and for president for President
Wonderland uh following up on the
inflation reduction act
based on today's discussions do you
think that there is a minority support
among member states to propose
additional joint funds in January thank
you
thank you very much for this very
important question we discussed the
necessity of creating a market
correction mechanism for gas prices it's
essential step for getting gas prices
under control
negotiation is quite long due to its
very technical nature
and we agreed that the deal must be
closed on Monday on extraordinary energy
Council by ministers and I think that
everyone is aware of this deadline
and are ready to for compromise
I'd just like to add firstly I am
confident that an agreement can be
reached this coming Monday secondly I'd
like to refer to the conclusion so I
think historic in the wording Church of
our European Council because we decided
to invite the ministers to finalize the
agreement on the 19th of December
that's uh
a phrase which we've only seen this time
and puts pressure on a minister and I'm
confident uh everything will be done to
make sure that we have an agreement next
Monday so the repo EU consists of up to
300 100 billion euros as you know this
is 20 billion fresh money and it is the
rest is loans that have not been taken
up by Next Generation EU now I have to
come with a proposal first of all before
I can predict what the reaction of
leaders is and the proposal will come in
January and then we will see the
reaction the overall reception and the
overall analysis of the problem we are
facing was very clear and very unanimous
what is our problem we have we are world
leader in clean tech
and we need to keep this leadership
we are competitive don't get me wrong we
are competitive because today the
European cleantech sectors
have to compete with the rest of the
world on a level where they have two to
three times higher energy prices in the
past they had two to three points times
and higher energy prices in the past
than for example the United States
this has now increased through the
rising Energy prices so the pressure
through the energy prices on for example
the clean tech sector but also other
cutting-edge Industries this pressure
has increased and on top comes the
massive subsidies of the United States
for investment in the United States and
what is important now is
that we do not run into a situation
where this cutting-edge industry is
making its next investment decision in
the United States and not in the
European Union because of as I said the
subsidies in the United States plus here
the high energy price environment
and what we have to do is to be able
to targetly and time Limited
support this
specific sectors and I would add to the
clean tech sector Quantum Computing AI
biotechnology
and other topics that are of utmost
importance for the modernization of our
economy we have to make sure that they
are able to have the transition from a
fossil fuel based Energy prices today
towards Renewables in a few years
that are homegrown that are much more
affordable and of course that are secure
so this transition we have to accompany
and we have to bridge
and that's where the specific
Investments are for
a
sovereignty fund could for example
enable for the first time funding on the
European level
of our important projects of common
European interest hydrogen is a
classical one
uh the ipcis
and these are the steps we have to do
now to really keep this as I said World
leading industry here in this critical
time
thank you madam president one last
question maybe for check TV yes better
television thank you I've got a question
to both of the presidents on the
presidency again you both have marked it
as successful and my question is is this
have the last six months somehow changed
your view on the checks and is this
going to somehow change their position
within the Block in the future thank you
we we we had no doubt that the trend
presence would be an excellent
presidency and and this is the case uh
and and it's uh really clear that uh the
the way uh the shed presidency acted to
to protect the unity to take so many
decisions and so many difficult topics
it showed a credibility of the church uh
presidency and the Czech Republic and
the state authorities
so we always thought that czechia is
amazing and the last six months six
months proved that in any respect uh you
even are amazing when you are the
presidency of the European Council but
this country has even much much more
virtues
thank you prime minister thank you
presidents best wishes to all of you and
see you next year
thank you